joining me in the studio tonight is
comedian and actress shappy horsandy who
was born in Iran and thanks so much for
coming in to speak to us about this I
know that you've been trying to keep the
protests at the Forefront of everyone's
uh mind and showing your solidarity
um let's talk about just what we've been
seeing this week you know 40 days have
been marked a lot has been unfolding and
from what little imagery that we are
getting out of Iran because they're
trying to shut down people's internet
they're trying not to allow us to see
what's going on every day there seems to
be another young person who's been
killed and more tragedy
um it's horrific and today in
Balochistan at least 93 people massacred
on Friday prayers we know that a girl's
school was given no they were given the
orders to attack the girls there because
they were they were vocal
um and for us here it the fact that they
are shutting down the internet shutting
down phone lines means that it matters
to them it matters to the regime that
the International Community know about
this and they support the protesters so
our job here is to give them that
support and give them our awareness cut
any ties we have with the regime really
and truly support
um the protesters in Iran to give them
just keep carrying on giving them the
strength to make those changes from
within Iran and it's it's a it's my my
duty I nearly said my pleasure but it's
my duty to be here to talk about it and
do whatever I can because I'm one of the
ones who escaped this regime you know I
wanted to ask you about that because
obviously here we know you as a comedian
and
various other things you've done and and
you yourself had to flee around with
your family
yes so we were one of the millions I
think who eventually got out of Iran
because uh people supported the
revolution for all sorts of different
reasons but it wasn't
um wasn't what anyone expected you know
we um we had to get Asylum here and for
a long time
um there were you know we'd talk about
going back you know you must speak Farsi
because when we go back to Iran but the
regime didn't change they got
the country into such a Stranglehold and
they implemented the most brutal
punishments to anyone who stepped out of
line the tiniest voice of dissent was
they came down on in the most brutal
it's very difficult to properly explain
to people how terrified people are of
this regime
um to this and that's a Nuance isn't it
because masoomini wasn't not wearing a
head scarf she was wearing it she just
wasn't wearing it in the right way
according to them and yeah and I think
another from all the interviews I've
done and I've seen what you've been
saying too is it's very hard to explain
to people that the Iranian people are
not entirely represented by this brutal
regime these are are people just like
you and I and and many others around the
UK full of talented people who want to
live a life of Freedom our culture is
very very different to the the people
who are
um the heads of the regime and what is
really important to recognize it's
happening now that of course this
started off as a reaction to the
brutality of the morality police but now
we are seeing the mother of Nika
chakrami who gave a very powerful speech
today and everyone is Nico was also
murdered age 16 and While She Was Out
protesting and the people in Iran are
chanting magbal dictator death to the
dictator that is huge to find the
courage and the voice to finally after
40 plus years to say down with this
regime death to the dictator I never
dared dream that this would happen in my
lifetime and it is and it is a very
um uh traumatic time because people
people's lives are on the line Young
young people I mean if you see the
pictures of people that are giving up
their lives is their
so young and it brings up a lot of
trauma however we all have to be strong
for them and I'm so grateful to a media
Outlets who are giving people like me a
voice because this is not something
that's going on over there this is my
life and my my people my language and my
other country you know I have two and
very lucky look I can I can see the
tears in your eyes as you're speaking
and I can see the emotion and the
solidarity you're feeling with the
people and as you say they are literally
putting their lives on the line and it's
on an hourly daily basis isn't it and we
have seen many protests in Iran before
this one is different
this one is different this generation is
different this is the generation that
has the internet this is the generation
that doesn't wasn't aware or alive when
in 1979 they're like going what is this
and this is the generation 4 change you
know the young change things nothing
none of the freedom freedoms we have in
this country happened by accident it's
because people fought for them and died
for them and
um this generation
are 14 and 15 and out protesting because
they don't feel
that the future that this regime has in
store for them is something they can
stomach
um I've never seen such a thing before
in Iran and I think this time with the
internet with the voices that we have
abroad with the way that we can connect
with each other we really really have to
pull together and support the people in
Iran and talk about them
as much as we can and and that is why we
invited you in and thanks so much for
telling us so much about what's happened
today and what's been going on in Iran
over the last few weeks Chaparral Hall
Sandy good to have you in the studio
thank you